لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
نحن الأرقام
الوَاحِدُ ثَابِتْ وَاقِفْ وَيُفَكِرْ
One
والإثْنَانْ تحني لِتَنْظُرْ
Two
وَالثَلاَثَةْ شَوْكَةْ لَدَيْهَا أَسْنَانْ
Three
والأَرْبَعَةْ جَمْعُ اثْنَانْ واَثْنَانْ
Four
والخَمْسَةْ كَالكَعْكَةْ عَلَيْهَا سُكَّرْ
Five
وَاحِدُ إثْنَانْ ثَلاَثَةْ أَرْبَعَةْ خَمْسَةْ
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
نحن الأرقام
سِتَّةْ عَلَى السَطْرِ صَارَت تَنْظُرْ
Six
وَالسَّبْعَةْ للأَعْلَى مَدَتْ كَفَّيْهَا
Seven
ثَمَانِيَةُ قَدَمَاهَا للأَسْفَلْ
Eight
والتِسْعَةْ بَالُونْ مَعْقُودٌ بِعَصَاهْ
Nine
العَشَرَةْ كَالوَاحِدْ بِجَانِبِ حَصَا
Ten
سِتَّةْ سَّبْعَةْ ثَمَانِيَةُ تِسْعَةْ عَشَرَةْ
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
نحن الأرقام
هيا نعد من الواحد
وَاحِدُ One إثْنَانْ Two
ثَلاَثَةْ  Three  أَرْبَعَةْ Four  خَمْسَةْ Five
سِتَّةْ Six سَّبْعَةْ Seven
ثَمَانِيَةُ Eight تِسْعَةْ Nine عَشَرَةْ Ten
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
نحن الأرقام